management
what this program offers you how it
helps develop your skills
with enrollment steps for those of you
who are interested in taking the program
and I'll try to answer your questions
the the discipline of General management
I'll talk a little bit about General
management for a second and then I'll
mention the fact that it's gone through
a great evolution in the last several
years so
General management actually
arose out of the World War II and
post-war period
where
concepts of Scientific Management
started to come out of business
a lot of it was driven by the need to
produce
uh weapons of war for that struggle so a
number of
different American firms started the
process of uh World War II understanding
how to
um
manage large organizations and
Enterprises efficiently
um the concepts of management from
businesses pre-war had not
lived up to the needs of that
increased production environment
um
so after the war
those
general managers
um
expanded the number of Business Schools
and management schools MBA programs
around the world
um they also for example trained
Japanese business Executives in
principles of quality management
um things that then
a few decades uh let the Japanese
manufacturers lead the world in quality
and efficiency
since then of course the principles have
spread throughout the world but even
those principles from the 1970s and 80s
have become dated
um
areas of
General management Human Resources
management
um
Information Systems management all the
different aspects of Enterprise and
general management have really undergone
a huge transformation in the last
several years since the Advent of the
pandemic
and that's caused structures and
techniques and and methods of management
to have to go through a
rapid Evolution as people move to remote
work
um as
customer contact became a non-contact uh
online method and as digital
Technologies came to the Forefront so we
live in the digital economy now and
digital economy requires digital Savvy
managers whether you are in an online
business or whether you're in a
traditional manufacturing business that
produces goods in a factory
um
digital systems and tools
and digital methods are integral part of
General management so
managers have to understand digital
technology it's applications in managing
Enterprises in a digital world and
as I mentioned even most traditional
Industries depend on it so
the
field of management is evolving rapidly
it requires you to keep up
uh you need to have a broad range of
skills if you are in General management
and your aspiration is ultimately to
move into executive Management in an
organization then you need skills of
General management understand the
principles
um which include economics accounting
and financial management you need to
understand operations and Supply Chain
management
you need to understand of course
marketing and sales management you need
to understand leadership Human Resource
Management you need to understand
business analytics and then you need to
be able to look ahead into business
strategy and use the technique of design
thinking to understand and empathize
with your customers better
and you need to understand
the digital disruption we're living
through and how to leverage that for
innovation in your organization so
this is a
spectrum of skills that you need to
succeed in general management and
that opens the door to a career path
where you can move from a level of a
group or department manager to a
division manager
a functional area director like the EP
or cxo of a particular part of the
company
Chief Financial Officer Chief
manufacturing officer that type of thing
where you need to have the broad
background of General Management in
order to be able to interact with other
departments and also manage your
department well then you move up to a
general management type of position
EP senior VP and president
and then the c-suite or the managing
director CEO
cxo as I mentioned all of these types of
Physicians lead up and and carry you
through to the whatever aspiration you
have within your organization or if you
have the aspiration to start your own
organization
but you need to have
the strong General management background
to do that
so that leads to our first poll question
hope we are all tracking along if you
have questions for me please put them
into the Q a
function of Zoom or into your chat box
in your streaming services your chat or
comment box and we'll try to take those
in the Q a portion at the end but I have
a question for you first
which is what has stopped you up till
now from taking a program
uh to certify yourself in general
management
so is it because you can't find a
program that has a curriculum covers all
of the skills we talked about uh is it
because you don't feel that you'd come
out of a program with practical
experience that you'd be able to to
demonstrate those skills
somebody
uh whether an employer or a interviewer
um is it because you
have looked at pre-recorded video
programs and decided that that's not a
really efficient way for you to learn or
is it because your work schedule
has precluded you from having the time
to do it
so the numbers are starting to slow down
and I'm going to give you five seconds
please to get your answers in
and we'll close the poll
three
two one
so uh
it's interesting as I run a number of
webinars for uh simply learning on our
partners
um
these numbers distributions change today
it's a fairly flat distribution
people have said they can't find a
program with a fully comprehensive
curriculum about the same number said
that they couldn't find the one with
practical exposure where they come out
of the program saying here's the work
I've done
and then almost as many have said that
the work schedule
their personal life
make it difficult to find the time
so let's move on
and talk about
this program and how it relates to those
things
oh
I apologize this is the executive
program in general management executive
certificate certificate program in
general management not data science for
business decisions apologize for that
typo but this is a program with the
QR code will take you to the correct
oh
program page if you're interested uh
comprehensive curriculum with an
industry aligned path I'm going to share
that with you with integrated labs and
Hands-On projects for practical
experience we have
a platform and this is the reason that
IIM indoor is selected simply learned to
work with as the delivery partner for
this particular program
we provide a platform that gives you
access to online live virtual classrooms
from your desktop or laptop
uh you can actually pick the programs or
review materials from your mobile device
if you wish although the screen size may
make it a little difficult but it's
available to you 24 7 on any device
and it allows you to fit in your
studying uh to your particular schedule
be part of the program that is uh
fixed to a particular timetable is the
lecture schedule where you do have to uh
show up to the live virtual classrooms
at the appointed time but everything
else in between your case studies
projects
other review materials are available to
you 24 or 7 and you have 24x7 support
for using that so
again I apologize for that typo this is
the
program certificate
of the type that IIM indoor issues you
at the end of this process it's a
six-month program
and
you have access as I mentioned to the
projects case studies integrated lab
work
you have live classes from the IIM
indoor faculty and at the end you will
earn a two-year
alumni status for my I am indoor and
simply learned
we sponsored that for you and you have
the option during this program to take
an uh campus immersion for three days in
indoor um that's an additional cost
element of the program so that's at your
option
now IAM indoor is an Institute uh Indian
Institute of Management
uh or which was established in 1996.
uh it has an auxiliary campus in Mumbai
and it offers an array of different
business and Management
Programs post graduate diplomas
it is ranked seventh in the National
institutional ranking framework by the
Ministry of Education
and it is ranked 25th in Asia the global
MBA rankings so
um of course it's fully accredited by a
csb Amba and efmd and
this is a program that will give you
recognition
wherever you take the certificate so
we're very proud to be the delivery
partner for IIM indoor
this is The Advisory board for this
program
you'll hear from
one or two of these folks shortly
um
the professors are drawn from the
different departments including Finance
and Accounting economics marketing
operations
um quantitative techniques
uh
organizational behavior and Human
Resource Management Group so
all of the different
aspects are drawn on
or the faculty for the
certificate program
and your eligibility for the program
allows you to draw from any business
background or industry sector you don't
have to come out of
any particular industry or any
particular function
um
do have to possess a bachelor's degree
so you must hold a bachelor's degree
with 50 or higher marks in any
discipline whether that's a technology
discipline a financial discipline a
commercial discipline business
liberal arts any of the different
backgrounds
you do also have to have two or more
years of work experience so this is not
a program intended
for
brand new graduates who have come out of
University without any business
experience or work experience in the
Working World and it's not for people
who are still at the University
unfortunately so you do have to have
that bachelor's degree you do have to
have the two years of work experience
because I am indoor
set on making sure that you have the
background you need to succeed in this
program
otherwise doesn't make sense
for you to take the program unless you
have that very high
chance of success
whole question for the audience
um
how many years of experience do you have
well we want to know if you meet that
qualification so
foreign
we'll leave this open briefly because
it's a fairly simple question
and
I'll close the poll in about 10 seconds
so please get your answers in
and we'll close in five
four
three
two
one
all right
so about 40 percent of our audience are
people who are currently studying
uh another 25 percent are people who
might not quite be at the two-year
minimum mark
um
have about
a little more than a third of the
audience are people with uh certainly
three or more years of experience so
again if you're shy of the two-year Mark
or if you haven't earned your decree yet
we encourage you to keep in touch with
us and to ask us all the questions you
need to know about this program
um for the time when you are fully
qualified to take it but in the meantime
let me
move on to what the program really is
How It prepares you
so
I'm going to allow
one of the professors
currently working as associate professor
in marketing area at Indian Institute of
Management indoor welcome to the
executive certificate program in general
management
excuse me
I wanted to check the channel
in collaboration with simpler
established in 1996 the Indian Institute
of Management indoor has been a leader
in the field of management education and
seek to be contextually relevant
business school with a world-class
academic standards that develop socially
conscious managers leaders and
entrepreneurs with content prepared by I
am indoor the program offers a
unprecedented view of various management
functions and will be helping the
participant to understand multi-facets
issues in management
let me introduce to all the other
professors whom you would be meeting
Professor Siddharth raskogi would be
taking your course on economics for
business in this course you would be
talking about the basic framework of
Economics which is essential for any
good manager then we have Professor
Swami ranjindas who would be talking
about accounting and financial
management trying to help us to
understand about financial statements
and the accounting practices which are
required in an organization then we have
Professor hasmukh gajar who would be
talking about operations and Supply
Chain management where he would be
talking about some fundamental
principles which Drive operation and
Supply Chain management in an
organization then we have Professor
Aditya birlou who would be talking about
marketing management which covers the
concept of brand consumer and all the
stakeholders who are interested in
delivering a value to an organization
then we have Professor Amitabh kudwani
who would be talking about human
resource management and the role of
leadership and management where he would
be covering some drastic foundational
topics related to human resource
management and some steps which would be
required to Leading them successful
who would be talking about business
analytics and digital Innovation which
will help organization to take the big
Steeps of changes in the today's Digital
World then we have Professor sumrita
Abbas who would be talking about
business strategy and how to connect all
the pins of functional management
together to execute corporate strategies
then we have professor satinan and Deng
manegal who would be taking uh sessions
about design thinking and how these
ideas can be useful in terms of creating
organizations which can innovate at a
very rapid pace
the online General Management program
will provide a broad overview of the
business environment and the new
essential of business strategy for
Learners who want to transition from
functional strategy to a business
strategy room this program includes
master classes by I am indoor faculty
campus immersion at I am indoor campus
for three days job assisted support by
simply learn where Learners get an
access to job players resume building
one-to-one mock interviews and so on and
finally alumni status and certificate by
I am indoor
combining the best of Industry expertise
and academic rigor this executive
certificate program in general
management ends with a Capstone that you
can use to show your skill and expertise
to potential employers
we look forward to welcoming you on
board the program cheers and all the
best
[Music]
all right
so that was a brief overview of the
program let's go a little bit deeper
into it and
um
the program builds up your general
management skills in a stepwise fashion
so
you have a total of 13 modules from the
orientation to the Capstone
um
these are all as I said delivered online
you do have the option of taking some of
them in the
on-campus immersion
that's an additional cost element of the
program if you choose to to undertake it
but we start off with an orientation
session which gets you
um
an overview of how the program will flow
what the online
environment will look like how to use it
then from that you start the actual
classes first with Foundations of
Management to give you the broad
overview of the field then moving into
economics and
how businesses uh function in order to
earn profit uh accounting and financial
management
court and score keeping a business
operations and Supply Chain management
are looking at how your business
actually delivers your product or
service to the customer marketing
management how you communicate to
potential customers and existing
customers
what you offer and how you will deliver
it to them
um human resources
management of
people who make up your Enterprise
how to motivate and direct them
business and analytics again getting to
the digital part that I emphasized
earlier uh understanding how to use data
to become a data-driven organization
so that you can make decisions based on
actual
observations of the real world rather
than gut feeling
um and knowing when to trust your gut
versus
um when to turn to the data
management and Leadership
uh of course are thought of as the core
strategies of General management
but of course they're just one component
although a very important one business
and strategy as the professor mentioned
if you're transitioning from a
functional role and your job is to
currently to do make sure that one part
of your business functions properly
this helps to open up your thinking to
what are the strategies that your entire
Enterprise have to follow in order to
thrive and grow
design thinking is a discipline that
allows you to develop empathy with your
customers and understand how to craft
your products and services
so that they Delight your customers
and therefore
beat the competition
digital disruption and Innovation again
dips into the domain of how has our
world changed as digital technology has
broadened and deepened into our lives
what what ways can we take advantage of
that to innovate
then we finally give you the opportunity
to tie all of this together in a
Capstone project
um we're basically
you create a management business plan
for
an Enterprise based on a case study or
based on
a situation that you want to bring to
the to the program so
this takes about six months these are
about two week modules
and they're all delivered on the simply
learned learning environment yeah going
to let this individual talk about how
that works and give you a glimpse into
it
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn you set the course
timeline that meets your busy work and
home schedule and keep track of your
progress every step of the way we'll
help you stay on plan with automated and
24 7 human support at the core of our
programs are our live virtual classrooms
where you interact Real Time with
trainers that are recognized leaders in
their field there you'll review key
Concepts get questions answered and
interact with your peers the important
reports on the audience if you notice
are demographics this is super useful
especially if you're running ads for
example foreign
by looking at these numbers you'll be
able to understand the age range of
people that you should be targeting
you know what you could just focus only
on that age category show your
advertisements to them very useful
that's not all you get to learn from
faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes ask
your questions to top industry leaders
in exclusive ask me anything sessions so
other another interesting question on
the chat box and say that oh to optimize
in YouTube you can use the rising
session of Google Trends and optimize it
okay so let's go back to here right here
where it says web searches and you can
see that there's going to be the YouTube
searches okay so now you can see that
the YouTube searches is going to be so
there's a option uh under not just web
search and there's going to be a YouTube
search okay so just go ahead and click
on YouTube search and you should be able
to optimize your search results
so what is Instagram app Instagram apps
with virtue when we come across any sort
of original video
apps would appear within those video
contents so you will be taught when you
are watching an original video and leave
you a video app and then go back to the
original video
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice tackle practical
problems with multiple projects and
simulations and work on a real world
Capstone project that you can showcase
to Future employers your learning isn't
restricted to just live classes explore
our highly effective self-learning
videos and other resources to fine-tune
your learning and remain up to date
always you can focus on different
learning approaches by subject to
personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn so
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
okay
I wanted to share that with you because
it gives you an idea of how the
mechanics of the program work when
you're sitting at home or in your office
and taking the courses
you get as you could see at the very
beginning of the video you get an
overview of the entire curriculum of
your program so you can see where you
are how far you've gotten how far you've
gotten in each of the courses as each
course completes you get access to the
following course so it keeps you in a
sequence and on a timeline that gives
you the the best chance of success
the online virtual classroom allows you
to interact directly with your
instructor they can share their lecture
materials live with you you can share
your questions live with them interact
with other people in that virtual
classroom you have the tests and
assessments that you do at the end of
each module to make sure that you've
mastered the material you also have the
the projects and the case studies that
you do during each module to as our
representative said
to do
learning by doing
redundant to learn by doing and to
um
get those practical skills really under
your under your skin
um
the Capstone project ties all of the
skills that you've acquired together
you draw on knowledge you gained in all
of the courses within the program and
you put together a final project that
you can then demonstrate as practical
experience of how you've used those new
skills in a real world type problem
um the system keeps track of your
progress gives you prompts to make sure
that you're on time for your classes and
uh on but on track for your progress
through the program
uh it unlocks the certificates that uh
to test the your completion of each
course and finally the
certificate that's issued by IIM indoor
it's finally unlocked by the end of the
Capstone project
and the platform is the one place to get
support both in the technical support
for the platform itself
when I understand how a particular
function works or where to find
something
contact us 24 7. but if you have also a
subject matter questions we do offer
support and we offer a a forum that
allows you to ask your peers for
their opinions and their help
as you're going through the program so
it's
an environment allows you to learn in
a social environment like a school
rather than in an isolated environment
just watching videos
we find that it's highly effective very
rich
and
will get you to the final result that
you're looking for
and what we'll talk about are those
final results
but first the cohorts of classes the
batches of different Learners have come
from a variety of Industries
they
as I said the program doesn't require
you to be from any particular background
so people from various
um
multinational companies uh
have sent their folks to IAM door for uh
training
people from it in Services backgrounds
but banking Financial
software Automotive manufacturing
Financial Services
telecommunications just a wide
spectrum of Industry experience
well those are the types of people that
you'll be uh
learning alongside
and
as the professor mentioned
simply learn also offers as part of this
program a job assist service
not a job guarantee program we don't
guarantee that you will get a particular
or a new job because of the program but
we do offer you full support in finding
another job if that's your goal if
you're taking this program
to be able to move up and maybe move
into a different organization we will
fully support that with the job assist
services so we do offer ongoing
um
educational events career events things
that you'll be able to access
for free on an ongoing basis we also
offer you
the real world projects and case studies
across industries that become part of
your portfolio with this program
including the all-important Capstone
um
and then we offer for six months after
you earn your IIM indoor certificate for
six months thereafter you have access to
the job assist services
that include access to a job portal
which gives you a ability to access
certain
um
exclusive jobs listed through IIM jobs
that's a valuable part of the program
but I think the more valuable Parts in
my opinion are the resume review and
rewrite service and the one-on-one
interview service
um in the modern world
your resume has to be more than a paper
document it has to be
accessible to AI filters that are part
of the automated tracking systems that
employers use
to get programs or to get the employees
through their their hiring filter
that means your resume has to be written
in a way so that the AI bot can read it
and understand it and match it up to the
job descriptions that the employer has
issued
that's a different way of looking at a
resume than the traditional for you
however
once you've gone through that AI filter
do you have to
fulfill the traditional job of the
resume to impress a human
reviewer who will see this on their
screen or on a piece of paper and say
this is the type of person that we want
they have the background they clearly
have the attitude and drive to succeed
you need to have a resume that
communicates those things so this resume
review and rewrite is a very important
service
similarly the one-on-one interview
service prepares you
for the next step which is if your
resume has caught the attention of a
recruiter or a hiring manager then you
will have to do interviews whether those
are by telephone by Skype or Zoom or in
person and
you'll have several layers of interviews
both to review your technical
qualifications your particular skills
and your experience but also
a layer of interviews that talk about
your uh fit culturally with the
organization your ability to play as
part of a team
and those softer skills so having the
opportunity to meet one-on-one with uh
interview prep people who will guide you
through mock interviews and help you
improve put your best foot forward is
extremely valuable as well
so
as I mentioned we have a series of uh
webinars
different from this one which talks
about a particular program
with IIM indoor we do General webinars
that talk about uh skills you'll need in
different
industry or technology sectors
how to find jobs how to use Career
Development tools how to
improve your career different techniques
everything from time management to
understanding new technologies and even
many courses in particular skills so I
take a webinar that's a one hour course
in technical programming skill or a
digital marketing skill or a general
management skill so these are available
to you at no cost
on an ongoing basis
so based on what we've shared
and I ask the audience
ask you all
are you interested in enrolling in this
program just based on what you've seen
so far
let this run
and
give you about another 20 seconds
and please be patient we'll be answering
your questions in the Q a shortly
all right I'm going to close the poll
and as you can see
uh more than three quarters just shy of
80 percent of the audience said yes you
are interested based on what you've seen
so far
I'm sure you get to take a look at those
numbers
so what I'm going to do is move on and
talk about how to enroll in the program
the enrollment steps are fairly
straightforward you you send
an email to us at ask us at
simplylearn.net as we are the delivery
administrative partner for this program
with IIM indoor and uh
our learning Consultants will take your
information ask you the questions you
need to answer about your educational
background your work experience
and um
your level of desire and interest in the
field of General management
then together with IAM indoor we review
the qualifications that you put forth
make sure that you meet the
prerequisites for the program
and then you'll receive an admission
offer from us
at which point you can then enroll in
the program and
the program starts again on
31 January so it's coming up about a
week
and our the classes schedule starts 18
February so typically classes at this
type are held on weekends or on
weeknight evenings uh you'll ask the
learning consultant about the particular
schedule for this cohort
the price as you can see is two lock 47
800.
um and you can stretch that out with uh
zero interest financing at eight
thousand two hundred twenty six rupee a
month
that allows you to pay this over time
rather than be faced with a large lump
sum pavement up front
again please contact us and ask us at
simplylearn.net
I will put that information into the
chat briefly
so
I'm going to
cut and paste into the chat
there we go
so you have that email address that you
can copy and paste and you also have the
link to the program page
so one question before and one question
after our q a
if you are interested in the program now
that you've seen
scheduling cost
how soon would you want to start are you
looking to start in that immediate
cohort that begins at the end of January
is this something that you're looking
further out
foreign
for a bit
give it about another 15 seconds
I'll close the poll in five four three
two one
so a little over ten percent of you are
interested in starting immediately
um and a little bit more than that are
interested in starting maybe the next
cohort after
uh for those of you who are looking six
months or more than six months out again
we recommend that you uh contact us and
ask us at simplyworm.net and from that
we'll keep you in the loop and keep you
informed about this program so that when
you are ready to make that choice
um you'll have everything at uh
for that decision so
let me
move on
we now are at our question and answer so
I'm going to
stop sharing
this is the presentation because you
don't need to stare at that slide
and
stare at me instead but I'm going to
also make sure we don't have uh whether
we have any questions here from our
LinkedIn audience excuse me
so I look
okay
I've not seen the answer here
uh
so
not seeing any questions from our online
uh
streaming audience
so I'll go back to our questions that
have come in through Zoom
so one attendee has asked how can we
apply this
and that's a actually great question
because
General management skills apply in any
role within an organization
you're going to be called on to manage
everything from your own work to your
local team to a department to a group to
complete functional stack within an
organization all the way to a division
or a
location
and As you move up in that hierarchy
you'll be able to apply more and more of
the skills
so that
you'll be able to take on a global role
within your organization
um but it's it's valuable if you work in
a particular uh
part of an organization to have the
overview of how the entire organization
works and what its strategy is so again
unless your ambition is to work within a
particular function which some people
um really enjoy I want to do a
particular uh
task like sales or they want to do a
particular task like a product
development
or a particular task like operations and
Manufacturing management
and all of those
um
you may be able to succeed in those
areas without
uh understanding of the general
background the general background of
General management will always be
helpful to you so it'll be your choice
whether the trade-off between the time
and and cost of the program
gives you that advantage in that
particular function if you're looking to
move into uh General management itself
and move up the organization this is an
extremely valuable program
apply it directly
uh
if I have asked a great question does AI
replace management
the interesting thing about AI is that
uh so far it's great at mimicking
people in certain respects but it is not
good at actually understanding people
um we have heard a lot recently for
example about
chat GPT as
the
flavor of the month in Ai and how it um
can write things
um
as if it was a human being
and all of the reviews I've read have
said it writes things as
if it was a
high school or college student
who
was tasked with reading about those
things and then writing a report about
them
um
it doesn't
get into
real understanding of creativity it
assembles different pieces
and
it puts them into an order that seems
reasonable
that's the same notion that you would
have
with um
excuse me notion you'd have with uh
AI in management
it will be able to emulate
as in behaviors of managers
but at present it can't actually
understand
who the people are that work in the
organization what motivates them and
um
how to keep them
engaged and on track that's one of the
greatest problems of management it can
certainly help find insights from data
that's one of the great advantages of AI
and machine learning is that it can find
patterns in the data that your
organization collects that aren't not
obvious to human observers simply
because there's so much data being
created
that it does take an automated system
to handle that flow and extract meaning
um but as far as replacing management
itself and
determining what an organization should
do what strategy it should follow how it
should execute that strategy and how to
keep
the organization's members focused on
that
we're not
at that level yet
um
suvik has asked I want to scale myself
doing short-term courses based on
current market trends which courses most
beneficial
so with respect to this particular
program from IIM indoor this is a pretty
short-term course it's six months it
covers the entire spectrum of management
skills and it brings those skills up
into the modern present day
so I think that
this program is well worth your
consideration Civic for exactly what
you're trying to accomplish
uh
what is the price of the course we've
covered that
I'm working as a guest
part-time guest faculty at a Government
College
with more than two years of work
experience
juvenile it sounds to me like you are
certainly eligible for this program
I'm presuming that as a part-time guest
faculty you are a bachelor's degree
holder at least
so you describe somebody who's fully
qualified for the program
what is the certificate that will be
offered for the IIM indoor program I
shared with you it is a certificate
issued by IIM indoor it is
um their attestation you've completed
their program
and um it's something that you can
demonstrate and that they will put their
full uh faith and
um reputation behind
Sanjay asks are what are the chances of
after completing this course that will
get the job there is no guarantee as
part of the services we offer we offer
um a the job assist program as I
described it and the other thing that we
can mention is that working with our
various Partners simply learn has
accomplished a track record where at
least 90 percent of our Learners report
that they have completed their
job goals once they finished
your training program so we're very
proud of that record
odds of finding a good job after this
program are very high
um is there any scholarship available uh
Sanjay I don't believe that our
scholarships or bursaries available uh
there is a payment plan that allows you
to uh stretch out the
National obligation over time
you would want to ask that question of
ask us at simplylearn.net and they will
be able to help you with uh that
particular question
is this a self-paced learning course
no
this is not a self-paced learning course
this is a a learning program that is
based on a live class schedule live
online class schedule
with self-paced learning components so
there's self-study components that you
do during the time between classes to
prepare for the next class or to
complete the
projects or assigned homework for that
particular class before the next class
meeting so
this is not
you get to sit on the computer and
um
do the work according to your um
own pace without any input from
the uh
in University or the the program
directors
this is a course where you have the
ability to schedule your work on your
own
Pace on your own
availability of time but you do actually
do the work on a overall schedule so
you're you're kept on a external Pace in
order to be able to finish
on time and effectively
what is the special Shiva asks what is
the specialization of this course sales
operations HR financial and this is a
general management course Shiva so it's
covering a spectrum it is not
specializing it is uh
taking a general overview across all of
the various disciplines so once you've
completed that you are able then to to
pursue further courses or further
programs that will uh let you dive
deeper and specialize but this is aimed
at making you into essentially what they
call a t-shaped manager where you have
the broad
spectrum of skills and knowledge across
the top of that t the bar of the T and
then you delve deeper into a particular
subject if that's of your interest to
bring the
but the upright of the T
what are the class hours and days in the
total duration of the months and uh IIM
indoor says this is a six-month program
that spans one or comprises 125 study
hours so
um you're talking five to ten hours a
week
um
if you add in the
work in between Class meetings so that's
the level of commitment you should plan
on making
um
what skills are needed to do great roles
in management Muhammad that I think
we talked about that and if you look at
the curriculum again when you review
this video or if you go to the program
page
you'll see that the curriculum talks
about all the different aspects of
management that
IIM indoor fields are necessary to be a
great manager
um
what is the average work experience of
the cohort I would ask that of ask us at
simplylearn.net
cohorts and because of the
commitment required tend to be
people who have a bit more experience
than just the minimum two years
and
I've gone through I'm not looking at any
questions
I haven't seen any come in from the
streaming audience and I've looked at
all the questions that have come in
through q a so at this point because
we're reaching the end of the hour
going to um ask one final
poll question of our audience
will we get annotation so
this final poll question is
do you need assistance with enrollment
if this is something that you like to
start
I think
quarter to a third of our audience said
that they're about ready to get started
do you need assistance from us
and what I will do is I'll put again
into
the chat the
ask us
mail
and
the link to the home page for this
program
and that's enough time for the poll
so almost a third of you are interested
in getting some assistance from us in
terms of how to enroll please contact us
at ask us at simplylearn.net
and I will
take this opportunity to thank you all
for being here again you can use the QR
code to go to the program page get
started through the process there or you
can email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
um
we thank you all for your time
your interest in the program
and we hope we can welcome you into the
Learning Community with IIM indoor
that concludes
this webinar for today